- Collecting milk bottles,
following brown road signs,
spotting village water pumps,
taking pictures of tombstones,
appreciating round-abouts...
These are dull things to do, aren't they?
Welcome to the Dull Men's Club?
(music)
(ding)
I am Grover Click.
I'm assistant vice president
of the Dull Men's Club
and one of its founders.
The Dull Men's Club is a
group that get together
to celebrate the ordinary.
Eh, it began in the
1980s, a long time ago.
We began in New York City,
and later I moved to London,
and the Dull Men's Club followed me
and has grown here in England as well.
It's got members both
in England and America
and across the world.
The last time we did a round-up,
putting all things together,
it looked like we had about 5,000 members.
So here are the people that do things
that some people think are dull.
Here's Steve:
- Hi, I'm a milk bottle collector.
I have some 20,000 milk bottles
from not just the UK
but all over the world:
Germany, France, South
Africa, Hong Kong, Portugal.
I've got Iranian bottles.
Uh, I don't like milk at all.
I just don't like it.
(laughing)
- [Mr. Click] And we have some women
that are interested interested
in the Dull Men's Club.
Here's Amanda:
- My quirky hobby is randomly
following brown tourist signs.
- Yep, you heard her right.
- I get inspired to turn off
the road whenever I see one.
I found it very hard not to.
I follow brown signs around the UK,
and indeed, the whole world.
So, I've now been to
thousands and thousands.
- [Mr. Click] We also have a member
that appreciates round-abouts.
- I'm Kevin, and I'm the president
of the UK Roundabout Appreciation Society,
also known as Lord of the
Rings, that's my official title.
I have taken thousands of
pictures of round-abouts
even when I'm abroad on holiday.
I know a lot of people would
find my hobby quite dull,
but it's bright being dull.
It's sexy being dull.
- And next is a member that is just dying
to get into a graveyard.
(screeching sound)
(woeful music)
- I'm a tomb traveler, and I take pictures
of famous graves around the globe.
I probably have at least
four or five hundred
on various parts of the world:
Kennedy, Martin Luther King,
Bruce Lee and Brandon Lee,
Elvis Presley, Ludwig van
Beethoven, Charlie Chaplin.
Well, I don't feel that I'm a dull man,
but people have said that,
but I prefer to think
that I’ve got a rounded,
albeit interesting way
to take my mind away from work.
- And we have Dick, who is
spotting village water pumps.
- And it all came about by accident.
Ten years ago, somebody pointed out
a tiny little pump by
the side of the road,
and almost every village you went through
I'd say, "There's a pump,"
and we'd slam the brakes on,
jump out and take a picture of the pump.
- It's okay to be dull.
There are a lot of studies being done now
that boredom has got benefits.
We're not so interested
in the glitz and glam;
we're quite happy with
simple things in life.
(upbeat jazz music)